hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher one of most frequent occurrences
that happens to me at a parent-teacher
night is you know a parent saying ah
look I'm really weirded out by how
different this is to me I you know and
Ivan even experiences myself my kids who
are in primary school and I'm a
mathematics teacher and the jump
strategy the bridging strategy this is
all news to me but I think what's
important is that I'm willing to say
okay well maybe I can I can learn a bit
about this - rather than recoil from it
and just say it's different
therefore it's bad I think in this world
in which you know there is such a rapid
pace of change there aren't people who
exist anymore who just have one career
one job one company and they just do
that forever people of our parents
generation already know this and so they
need to apply that to the way learning
happens of course we should expect that
learning is going to shift and change
with the times and I really hope that
that happens because otherwise we are
preparing our students for a world that
is not it's just a mirage it won't exist
by the time they get there and we
already know you know if a kid is in
kindergarten right now they going to
enter full-time work in the 2040s that's
going to be amazingly different to now
and so we want to make sure that our
teaching practices are similarly
amazingly different so they can prepare
our students for that world
[Music]